[Musique]
l'ampleur de cette opération c'est quand
même une opération d'un peu plus de 1000
logements qui va s'étendre sur 500
mètres de long dans un axe est ouest
avec un sillon paysager qui traversera
donc du parc du moulon jusqu'à la plaine
des sports
l'ensemble des opérations ce sillon nous
l'avons voulu ouvert au public en cours
de journée est fermé la nuit pour la
tranquillité des futurs habitants
bien entendu dans cette opération nous
avons du logement social mais également
du logement locatif intermédiaire
c'est-à-dire que pour le parcours
résidentiel des futurs habitants il y à
des produits en accession bien entendu à
la propriété du logement locatif
intermédiaire et du logement social donc
un peu toutes les gammes de logements
cette opération sera livrée à l'été 2010
neuf dans sa première phase soit les
4500 m²
les équipements publics et les 800
premiers logements va parler de défi
parce que
c'est un territoire évidemment du grand
paris mais une fois qu'on a dit ça ça
suffit pas parce que il était hors de
question évidemment de copier coller des
éléments parisiens et les amener ici à
sac
ici il
il ya un grand plateau il ya un
territoire absolument extraordinaire
avec une très grande profondeur un grand
paysage et donc par conséquent il
fallait donner la chance à chaque
logement véritablement de ne pas être
dans un enfermement
alors qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a fait
des îlots verts avec ce qu'on appelle un
grand sion paysage est cueilli 100 m il
va du parc du moulon à la plaine des
sports
les enfants pourront jouer là parce que
ça sera sécurisé par des grives mais le
matin plutôt que de prendre le trottoir
là où là les voitures et les bus là où
il ya du bruit on pourra traverser le
sillon et à les emmener ses enfants à
l'école dans un lieu un peu particulier
la deuxième qualité
si vous voulez c'est que je suis assis
dans mon séjour j'habite non pas sur rue
mais j'habite sur le sillon et bien le
soir de temps en temps en levant les
yeux je peux voir le soleil couchant sur
la plaine des sports où le matin le
soleil se lever sur le parking où l'on
rit ça c'est ce qu'on appelle des
échappées c'est à dire ne pas être
enfermé mais être vraiment dans un
quartier ouvert
[Musique]